BUT HERE'S THE DEAL, IF
INCENTIVES HELP US BEAT THIS
VIRUS, I BELIEVE WE SHOULD USE
THEM.
WE AL BENEFIT IF
WE GET MORE PEOPLE VACCINATED.
))
((BRIAN LOFTUS))
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN ASKING
-- SAYING 90 MILLION AMERICANS
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE SHOT
HAVE YET TO START THE PROCESS.
((DENISE VALDEZ))
THE PRESIDENT IS CALLING
COMMUNITIES TO OFFER 100 DOLLARS
TO EVERY PERSON WHO GETS THE
VACCINE.
IT'S A PLAN ALREADY IN THE WORKS
HERE IN CLARK COUNTY.
((BRIAN LOFTUS))
THE I-TEAM'S DAVID CHARNS WITH
QUESTION: WHAT ABOUT THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS ALREADY
VAXXED?
((DAVID CHARNS))
THE ANSWER TO THAT IS NO
-- THIS PROPOSAL WOULD GIVE 100
DOLLARS TO ANYONE WHO BEGINS THE
IS ALL IN ITS EARLY STAGES.
COMMISSIONER TICK SEGERBLOM
SAYS THE COUNTY COULD BUDGET 10
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
IN FEDERAL CORONAVIRUS RELIEF.
THAT'S 100-THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
CLARK COUNTY GETTING THE VACCINE
-- AND 100 DOLLARS.
YOU HEARD THE PRESIDENT CALLING
INCENTIVES.
COMMISSIONER SEGERBLOM SAYS AS
MORE AND MORE PRIVATE COMPANIES
REQUIRE VACCINES OR PROOF OF A
NEGATIVE TEST...
THIS JUST MAKES SENSE.
((COMMISSIONER TICK
SEGERBLOM // (D) DISTRICT E:
THE REALITY IS,
EMPLOYERS ARE GOING TO START
SAYING, 'WE WANT YOU TO EITHER
BE VACCINATED OR GET TESTED ON
YOUR OWN DIME, EVERY WEEK OR
TWICE A WEEK.
SO, WHERE THERE ARE
GOING TO BE SOME FINANCIAL
PENALTIES INVOLVED, WHEREAS WE
GIVE YOU THIS $100,
THEN YOU MAKE MONEY AS OPPOSED
TO HAVE TO
PAY MONEY.
))
((DAVID CHARNS))
THE COMMISSION WILL TALK
ABOUT THIS ON TUESDAY.
NEW WHEN YOU JOIN US AT SIX
TONIGHT -- WHERE COVID IS
SPREADING NOW --
WE'LL SHOW YOU WHICH ZIP CODES
ARE SEEING THE MOST CASES IN
THIS NEW SPIKE.
I'M DAVID CHARNS, 8 NEWS NOW.
((DENISE VALDEZ))
THIS LOCAL INCENTIVE
DOESN'T INVOLVE "VAX NEVADA
DAYS" --
THE STATE PROGRAM.